mark welcome back round two
round two yeah almost forgot about round
one
yup that was right after i took your
accept yourself program
yeah when was this like july june yes
wow yes
yep and that was the second time you had
offered the acceptor's health program
the one you did yeah the second time
yeah yep
and so since then you offered a third
one you've had over around 70 people go
through radical self-acceptance yes
and we've gotten to become a lot closer
since i came out to the netherlands to
start working with you guys the team
here
um
and
there's been the formulation of when the
next accept yourself program is is going
to launch and it finally
came together january 4th 2022
three-month program 12 sessions by mark
um
bentino massaro and corey katuna's guest
speakers
um
four powerful modules which i think is
going to be great for you to break those
down nice yeah um
awesome breakout groups
new breakup mentor new breakout mentor
yeah so exciting nice yeah so exciting
um
yeah just i think it'll be good for me
to also mention
to our audience that
like
yeah for me it was very funny when i
first you know i met you in costa rica
at the shift into permanent alignment
retreat
and then when i came back uh over the
summer i felt like oh like i was already
on the uh become the creator step of
know yourself accept yourself become the
creator
and it was funny on our first phone call
when i was sort of telling you like oh
like i feel like i have already uh went
through those first two steps and then
you were like well then you know you it
sounds like you're not actually full in
you're not all in into this program and
what it can actually offer you and that
like little reflection was like wait a
second like can i actually like still
accept myself deeper and more truly and
more honestly um than radically
and
then the answer was clearly yes because
there was so much that we uncovered
including my core lack belief
um
of wanting to be seen which we share
which is very interesting also it is we
can dive into that deeper we will yes
yeah and so there's all these core lack
beliefs and the more that you really um
radically
uh shine the light of awareness love
light onto them and ex fully accept them
the more you can actually embody purity
and the creator serving itself
shepherding itself
um
so yeah so i i actually uncovered so for
many of us i'm pretty sure like a lot of
people will be like i've already you
know done a lot of that work
i'm good
um
but there's a big deepening that can
happen especially from someone like mark
that like really does a great job with
the meditations and the personalized
guidance for each one of the people
that's taking the program for somebody
that's basically with who's been with
for six years now with bentino
who's on and off on and off yep who you
could say is one of the greatest
teachers on the nature of reality so
mark's been picking up these patterns of
consciousness and how to how to shepherd
really well so it's it's a great um
it's a great way to
to deepen your awakening really and
deepening deepen your service
so
awesome so let's uh let's talk about um
let's talk about the program and let's
talk about i think it'll be good for
basically you to give a little
um insight into the modules themselves
cool yeah
for that uh also to make it more clear
how this has operated in my life and how
like how subtle it can be
i'm gonna take you back to
we touched upon this in the previous uh
in the interview video with me yes and
so if you want to know more in depth
uh go back to that but in a nutshell
most of my life i was disconnected from
my heart and was either seeking outside
of myself for love
or
felt victim to
not being seen or
by the outside world by my friends by my
family by loved ones by people
women i fell in love with and all of
that
i had a big depression
about 11 years ago where
after a
extensive period of partying with party
drugs
being completely in love and connected
when on ecstasy
but when not
and by myself in my room i was like
totally depleted and uh and depressed so
i was laying on the floor in my
one bedroom studio apartment and
just having this moment
like eckhart tolle also had
in a way i cannot live with myself this
way
and realizing that
something had to change and so one of my
dear friends who pointed me to all these
spiritual teachers
he had already talked to me about
meditation and he showed me these two
practices
after i called him desperately like okay
now i want to know now it's not floaty
anymore
right i was totally judging meditation
yoga up until that point
and
and he's like okay do this these two
practices one
lay in your bed before you go to sleep
which was the most
anxious moments those were the most
anxious periods for me like before going
to sleep having panic attacks waking up
in the middle of the night sweating
like all these lack beliefs coming
together which i didn't know what that
was happening but looking back that was
what was happening
um
doing this practice of scanning my body
parts
feeling my in the inside of my shins the
inside of my thighs the inside of my
chest
and then
as my nervous system was calm
seeing these clothes pass by
and the clothes are the thoughts
basically so imagine laying on the grass
on the grass in the summer and these
little clouds are passing by and you're
like oh that looks like a donkey or that
looks like an elephant you know that
game right
so
this practice was the same but
instead of laying in the grass i was
imagining laying in the grass
and thoughts were clouds so normally i
would be
thinking about work
and i would already have thoughts about
oh i gotta go to work tomorrow and this
i don't like this colleague
oh five years ago
all that and but
to stop that the practice was
labeling it
as it was a cloud passing by so
oh work
oh my mom doesn't have family
and so
yeah i was combining these two practices
and they already like i already felt
calmer during the day and falling asleep
and three weeks into this and this is
why i'm telling this because it's it's
tying into the to what you just
described this now i'm already there i'm
already becoming the creator because
i've had this experience
um
i was laying in my bed and i had these
thought forms passing by as clouds they
weren't personal they were
humanity related and
the moment the images went to the future
i had this samadhi experience where i
became one with everything
or you could say i realized i was one
with everything
and everything is love
and i had always been seeking this
outside of myself but it was always
within me so there was this just huge
huge uh
experience
that was 11 years ago
it took me until 2019
so nine years of doing this work
meditating having glimpses of all these
different levels of consciousness
finding teachers like
muji and ekatoli and abraham hicks and
bashar and bentino and even having
traveled with bentino and helped him at
retreats and stuff and
i thought i was there
until i received a reflection
from bentillo himself saying
you're validation seeking and i'm
paraphrasing you but your validation
seeking shadow is still running the show
to some extent
and
you can eliminate it or you can let it
linger and
be on this stay on this journey the way
you have been in the last nine years
or you can eliminate it and
either way when you decide to eliminate
it i will be there for you to help you
and to guide you but if you don't then i
i can trust where you're coming from
quite similar to the journey we've been
on right yes
and i was it was painful it was
uncomfortable
looking at
my behavior seeing where
my core belief that i picked up my
childhood that good
something wrong with me
had hijacked my spiritual journey
and i was
saying to myself i'm already there i'm
becoming the creator but
this
program was still operating
on the background
and so that was for me like nine years
into my spiritual journey into my
awakening journey into my meditation
journey i realized i had thought i was
there but i didn't know
i was i wasn't
and that still is humbling to this day
that still keeps me on point that the
moment i believe
i am i have become
god
that's where i need to pay attention
because that's where it can it can slip
in yeah
and so
this is the work yeah of accept
accepting yourself
is accepting
that you picked up
some beliefs totally
from society from whatever you've
experienced in this life or beyond
but these core assumptions of lack and
limitation and not good enough
not worthy enough
something will happen to me if i express
myself i'm not safe all of that all of
those things
and that's the work we're doing that's
one of the biggest
components of the program yes like
actually identifying those and seeing
where
they are infused with our daily life and
and letting those go and accepting that
we have been doing that and where it's
coming from and yes
yeah so
beautiful
the modules yeah yeah and just the way
that mark recapped that is actually it's
more precise than when it's it's more
direct and it covers more of the
big picture and also the the individual
expression picture um
and it's really nice seeing how you've
evolved in the way you communicate it
since
six months ago
and so i'm really happy you gave that
that recap it's and it it
created a couple other
threads as we get to um the modules
it
one of the big ones is that um
mark took us basically also to
um
like knowing yourself where you you
become aware of your patterns and your
frames of life and you become really
earnest and sincere with
like
honest with understanding like where
you're coming from meaning like is
what's popping up right now in my
awareness is it something that is
um
something that i've been conditioned
with from the past from my family from
my friends from society at large is it
something that has to do with
unworthiness or separation or lack
belief um or is it coming more from a
place of of truly wanting to serve other
people
and
and so that's this ongoing purification
process and so to sort of become really
aware of what's showing up in awareness
um and then to um
and then to
to
like really lovingly radically accept
that there is some shadowy conditioning
and to not like it's a really common
thing it's like i'm already there um
and to and so to to know that like life
is and ben said this at the shift into
permanent alignment in costa rica that
um he's uh a self-purification engine
ongoing forever like this is the whole
thing it's a perfection perfecting um
it's always entangled like this and so
um
you know we will perpetually for the
rest of our life be improving um where
we're coming from to be more empty of
self-interest and to be more
mirror-like and more like a shepherd and
i think that's really important because
it will deepen all of
whoever's taking the program
and there's to be about 44 or so slots
yeah yeah yeah
um
so whoever is you know blessed and has
the will and desire to take this program
they're going to be blessed with
basically being able to come from a pure
place and so anybody that actually wants
to get into service to others in this in
this collective
um is going to be blessed and that's
that's such a good way to to view it
um
yeah thank you for that
so then that plays into um module two
which is accepting who you are not yes
cool yeah accepting who you're not which
is i'm not good enough
which is
i'm unworthy i'm there's something wrong
with me
all those
limiting
perspectives limiting point of views
about yourself are what you're not
and
it's safe to assume that
all of humanity has picked up those
beliefs as an identity
which yeah you're compensating for or
hiding from or fighting
or whatever
so
that is that is what i think it's one of
the most important modules and
it is a
program with four modules spread out of
over three months
but i have not decided yet
how it's going to
unfold because there's going to be
overlaps we're going to be keep coming
we're going to come uh keep coming back
to this
accepting who you're not yeah uh often
oftentimes
and another good way to visualize the
accepting who you are and who you are
not is like the sticker paper and then
the sticker that's on the sticker paper
or the tree and the vines
yes these are good or the painting and
the the the
canvas and the what's being painted on
top of it yeah
and the canvas
is who you are or what you are yes which
is
anybody who's watching right now it's
like
if you ask yourself earnestly the
question who am i
and anything that indicates i am this
person i am a male i am
a painter i am an artist i am a singer
those are all thoughts right but who are
you before that
before you're atlas yes before you're
the creator of this podcast like who am
i
and just let no thoughts
enter or
just ignore all thoughts like what is
that
so that is
the foundation
which we will start with so meditation
practices to point you to that so good
or another technique and i'm not going
to give it all away but
um is going outside and looking at the
bright blue sky or starry sky and asking
yourself
and again
anything that comes from the mind
afterwards is not it so to gently
ignore that
where do i end
yeah
right so that is the basis on which we
will do the work
uh which is accepting everything you've
pasted on top of that that is not in
alignment with your true self
and your your truth so this is your true
self but you also have like that this
whole uh that has chosen a certain path
on this planet which is what i mean with
that true self yeah
which is something we're going to be
doing at the end accepting your soul's
blueprint
accepting what you came here to bring
where
whether that's a coach healer painter
singer
artist
actor whatever that is
to actually accept that without any lack
yes without any lack yeah without as
with as little distortions and
conditioning as possible so honestly
seeing through it over and over and over
again until you can come from a more
empty pure place yeah so after we've
done the work like accepting who you're
not identifying
the core assumptions that have been
running the show
yeah
accepting those accepting that child
that picked those up yeah because what
you've been doing so far is telling the
child to get the [ __ ] out yeah yeah
like not believing but you're actually
believing in
those thoughts so
then what we're gonna do and i'm excited
about this one but it needs some
groundwork first is
accepting your past which were which was
where you picked up those beliefs in my
case i was bullied i was a small boy i
had freckles i had glasses
and my brother was also
not always nice to me
not that not i love my brother and it
was just brotherly
[ __ ] like nothing like
extremely abusive but just
mental warfare you know like
manipulating and
spinning my wheels so to speak and then
if i if my wheels if he couldn't spin my
wheels i would
bear the consequences so to speak
but through the work of accepting my
past and changing the narrative of my
past which is important but which can
only happen when you fully accept that
everything that happened
and everything that you started
believing in those moments where
impending lack was
seemingly present
changing the narrative which now
i look at my whole past as
kung fu training kung fu training that's
all it's such a good way to my brother
is my sensei
finally finally i blamed him for most of
my life for my suffering the moment i i
said i don't want to continue this uh
this relationship this way
and i started actually seeing him as a
sensei and just letting him letting him
live his life exactly he's on this path
now which i never would have imagined
yeah but it is powerful bro so it's
pretty powerful and so
you can hold on to the narrative that
you're not good enough you can hold on
to the narrative that there's something
wrong with you but if you hold on to
those then that's what you're gonna get
that's what you're gonna create that's
what you keep repeating
so if you want to live the jedi life for
that that's another way i look at my
life yes
jedi training totally then you get to
start seeing your past like that yes
exactly at school for yourself
it brought you to where you are exactly
it
molded you into
yeah who you are right now and to
to see it that way it makes it easier to
do the radical self-acceptance when you
see it as you designing your own school
for yourself like i designed my own dojo
on planet earth for myself to fall
asleep and become separate and become
located in the body and etc
and then to
seek some sort of truth and liberation
freedom awakening
to then
actually know myself my true nature and
then be able to see that ah now i can
serve my other selves that are aiming to
to do the same thing
and so when you when you create the
simple analogy that this was my school
for myself it sort of makes it easier to
um to see the past as something that is
like not
uh you oh yeah i've i've accepted that
because that's sort of also where i was
coming from is that i've accepted that
i'm good to go on that yeah and the
energy with the energy
doesn't lie right so the energy that you
did that way was resistance
the opposite of acceptance
i've accepted my best resistance
so the words
yes
they don't have any
any meaning
yeah
there's a whole new layer of resolution
that comes when you bring acceptance to
it and then you can
dig into these more like shadowy roots
and then you can more honestly um
see where you're coming from so that
it's yeah it's so good because for for
me and for you it was just such a
relatable thing for it's just that like
coming from a place where there's always
this like mixture of also wanting to be
seen or also wanting to be validated it
can't it can't work when you get to like
higher levels of service it won't work
it can work like in the baby steps of
service because some people won't really
see you also trying to be validated and
stuff when you get to higher levels of
service it will get seen right away that
you're also trying to be seen while
you're serving so the more that you can
honestly look and accept those shadowy
conditionings it actually purifies
the shepherding that you actually see
because that's the freedom the freedom
is where you can serve your other selves
with complete emptiness of self-interest
there's so much freedom there it's mwah
exactly you nailed it
um
you know
we've talked about this before but
when you have an agenda
when you have an assumption that
you're not good enough
to be seen
or you're unworthy
then when you bring that into your
service this that you bring the hidden
agenda of one thing to be seen as in a
certain way because you already believe
that you're not good enough
you already have that assumption so you
could argue that if is that actually
service
yeah
because
the reason you're doing it is to prove
yourself worthy
which
you believe in something that's not
that's inherently not true and there's
no proof whatsoever outside of your own
mind that that could be true that you're
unworthy so good
prove to me your unworthiness
prove it yeah right so
the work is to actually ex one accept
that you've
that you're still believing that
that
you're running from that program
literally
your operating system is running on the
program but you're also running away
from the programs you are afraid it
might be true that's why you're trying
to prove it wrong and you get like this
little hit
like a heroin junkie every time somebody
validates you yes yes
ah that means that
i'm good enough wow
but you believe you're not
so you need to keep getting the head and
that when you when you are with people
that have been on this patent that have
done this work and actually are
convinced
that there is no such thing as
unworthiness in the universe
then it stands out like a sore thumb
totally
so painful this dude believes he's not
good enough and with every move he makes
he's trying to prove that he's good
enough so it's not reliable yes
because he wants something yes he's
looking for something from others yes
covered in this fluffy rainbow i'm
service to others but it's all
[ __ ] yes if you actually look at it
without j it's not judgment it's
actually looking at what's happening
on i like
um
almost like us um
i'm looking for an english word more
subtly level no like a like
[ __ ]
oh pardon the profanity um
two people just left the livestream
because i said the f word
um
on the mathematical level oh yeah it's
just like this is what this is how the
universe works totally it is physics yes
it's great
it's like oh
there's here somebody believes in the
in the one thing that cannot be true
which is lack yeah
and is trying to find that proof that it
doesn't exist whereas the only proof is
found in here yes
yes
and then when you actually are convinced
in your worthiness and your inherent
words
just by the mere fact that you're here
yep
then you can be of service because
because what you then automatically do
is share it
and that's what this program is about
like i want to share
my path with people and
amazing that those three groups of
people that have gone through this
program in 30 days
and the reason why i haven't launched
one since july was because i've been in
the
uh restructuring phase of this because
i'm trying to condense 11 years into 30
days
and so three months feels better and
also because i talked to bentino about
it and he gave me some advice and i'm so
blessed and excited that he's gonna be a
guest speaker yeah and corey katuna as
well yeah feels really good yes
but
yeah so
i can only do this like this is my
journey i want to give this to people
that are struggling with the same things
and don't have to take 11 years to get
to that point or nine years in my case
yes
yeah the
the analogy that i i like using is that
the the cup is always full
the cup is never it's only mind that
makes the illusion that it's only like
half full or a quarter full yeah it's
like this this
is it's full
there are many ways to look at it as
still full
one way is just simple there are air
molecules on top of the water molecules
and it's still full
the other way of looking at it is
there's a tap there i can fill it up
so even when it's empty there's still
plentiful
exactly it's empty full is such a good
way it's a very very nice entangled way
to put it because
the purification process is emptying out
all of this conditioning
which comes through radical
self-acceptance and knowing the patterns
of how you express yourself
and then the fullness is like this full
cup that you are and that you
not only realize that you are but then
you perpetually express yourself as that
full cup or as a radiant sun in light
and mint
um
so there's no seeking
somebody else giving you light or giving
you water for your cup because it's
already overflowing
and paradoxically so
um
you won't have to seek for it but it
shall be given exactly
yes it's like infinity
it's so good yeah it's like you give you
receive back what you give in tenfold
yes but you're not looking for the
tenfold totally yeah it will just happen
because
i'm serving the hole so the whole serves
me yes
i need fuel yes i will receive the fuel
i need to serve people to serve humanity
to serve
this
mystery yes
and it's funny
yeah this planet is funny
and we are the ones that are doing this
work earnestly
this is it's not i don't want to be
dramatic but we are warriors in a way
because we are
uh
not fighting against but we are
resolving
the illusion of lack yeah and so
we are in the midst of a collective that
is focused on the only thing that
doesn't exist in the universe which is
lack so it is like oh [ __ ] yeah it's
it's crazy
but it's awesome and the work is
acceptance
whenever those thoughts come up
and and so this
so what practice i really love it but
i'm not gonna yeah dive into it yeah
that's it that's a great one for the
program and for actually more content
because we'll be pulling um clips from
the past three programs and putting
those out on um on the youtube channel
accept yourself youtube channel also on
instagram and so
you guys will see more clips emerging
from previous programs that will give
you a taste of what's being shared
um
do you feel like lack
runs
deeper than
separation
do you feel like those are about equal
there's just one sentence that comes and
reply to that and it's not directly it's
not a direct answer but
can you find both anywhere
i love them if you look for them such a
good reply
outside of
thoughts
yeah
can you give me uh this is great like
then to you and to you uh
uses this type of analogy but can you
give me a portion of lack like give me
some give me some of that give me some
lag give me some separation yeah give me
some separation show it to me like where
like can you make something out of it
yeah
well it's so funny because it it does
turn attention on the absurdity of said
uh creation yes yeah it's so good
and then it enables the speediness of
seeing through it
just so good
yeah
and i like that reply and and i like the
speediness and then
i also like
um sort of
actually like in when you do like sort
of investigate like your life and
like where lack may have come up or
where you may have assumed that like you
were separate from existence or that you
were unworthy
um these types of
things that
that also plays into the acceleration of
seeing through it so by earnestly
turning on the shadows through again i
think this is really important because i
did a lot
of it but i did it from
a
i did it without
people that
had already seen so many patterns of
shadows so like one of my main
excitements around coming here was that
i would be around a bunch of other
people that had already picked up some
of the most subtle patterns of how
consciousness expresses itself
and so
um that was one of my again my big
takeaways from taking the program was
that it's actually so worth it to
see how mark sees
how consciousness expresses itself and
where it comes from lack or separation
or unworthiness versus when it comes
truly from emptiness and fullness from
service
and
that creating a distinction there and
then like purifying where you're coming
from towards um
towards the creator purely serving
itself
is i think like the it's like the core
essence of the school
in a sense and so like you may as well
learn from some of the greatest teachers
in the school and see the teachers as
yourself
nice and
so so this is what i would say like
guys
this is such a great opportunity to not
only get deeper into knowing yourself
and accepting yourself but also opening
up the space for you to um really be
able to get to these um next levels or
these next densities of awareness love
light where you can really
feel yourself more purely in service
which is ultimately what you see because
you seek freedom and there's no greater
freedom than when you're totally
liberated from conditionings and when
you're
serving life your
sole purpose is to just serve life
um and this is also a great segue into
um no limit society
this ongoing um
training exclusive training program that
is being offered um
and it's a great opportunity to in a
sense see
like okay
after i get through accept yourself
there's a there's a hundred dollar
discount offered for april 2022 for new
enrollments into no limit society and
that's such a good way to continue doing
the work with the field
yeah and i i've attempted that uh after
previous programs uh but it never really
um
like i i just saw myself working with
these people and amazing people
all of them
and then and then what
like then they are left to their own
devices which
i did feel that was a component that was
missing
and not lacking
but um
and now
uh with this new structure of having a
three-month program and then
those who obviously uh
feel
that that's their next best step they
can
together enroll into no limit society
and continue to work there uh with you
me the continuous team and bentino
himself and
it just feels great it feels like a
great also bridge for those that aren't
yes yet
ready for a for a more intensive
container like no limit society is and
is becoming more and more uh yeah
yeah
yeah corey recently
said something to the to the kata guys
and it was around how um
ultimately um being
in the field itself
is what does the work it's what does the
purification and so
accept yourself is the entrance into the
field it's like your opportunity to
like recognize at a deeper level not
only how to purify where you are coming
from yourself but then also see
these patterns that are going to be
revealed to you you're going to begin
seeing those patterns in everybody else
and how they express themselves and so
that's where you can step in and become
a greater shepherd whereas before you
couldn't see those patterns
you couldn't see where people were
seeking validation or feeling unworthy
or and you didn't know exactly how to
serve them either um but now from doing
things like going to accept yourself
taking the program also shifting into no
limit society you'll become
able to see these patterns
like it's i i just i can't
i can't express how important it is like
everything is patterns and there's
if you're if you're truly
earnest about knowing your true nature
patterns of consciousness is where it's
at
um
that's where all the freedom is at and
that's where all the pure service is at
um
and then yeah it's almost like a like a
train
yeah
that you decide to jump on
yeah so in in your case have uh
you can track you can track back
when you're being purely of service
because that's just coming through you
naturally
and when you are
coming from
the pattern
of
means
you can when you you can track to the
difference you can actually look back on
yourself and your behavior and see that
that
the first example just goes naturally
there's no there's nothing there it just
flows out of you and the other one you
can track back to the energy of some
kind of insistence yes yes it's like i
jumped on the train of trying to
prove something
wanting something
and that is that where you can look back
on your
um how did you say it
pattern of consciousness yes and that's
the work like seeing that
oh
cool
and now i can see it in others as well
yeah
because i can feel i can start to feel
and instead of looking at what
somebody's saying
you become more and more sensitive to
the energy of where somebody's coming
from no not but six out of ten times i
don't even hear what somebody's saying
anymore
yeah you're feeling the vibe feeling
where it's coming from yes yes so good
is it coming from generosity or is it
coming from
consuming yes
nice
such a good contrast yeah
is it coming from generosity or is it
coming from consuming
um
and the honorable analogy is really
applicable here where he talks about how
it's just like
you know skiing down harder hills
over time so you know
this also plays directly into the
analogy of unfreezing your will
so if you're run by unconscious patterns
um it's kind of like staying on the
bunny hill
uh in skiing for snowboarding and that
when you
shine the light of awareness onto those
subconscious patterns
um
it's sort of like becoming a better and
better skier and over time you're
tackling harder and harder hills and
it's becoming more and more effortless
you're becoming more and more just one
with the game itself
which is just life and you're
you're skiing because you love the game
you're not skiing to be photographed and
to earn trophies and get points and all
this type of stuff
um
and this is a really great way to
to just make it simple like i designed a
school for myself
so that i would
create my own
lacks and separations and
conditionings to then liberate myself
from it by unfreezing my will by by
by caring about my own freedom by caring
about my own um the way that i show up
in life so that i'm not showing up to
try and extract things but that i'm
actually showing up to serve to serve
life and by unfreezing that will you
become a better and better athlete of
consciousness and then you can actually
play the game
um
yeah it's so good
then when something shows up
like in the program that you and you
were in uh
i was in costa rica and
we were diving into this
core core like belief
team and
i something had happened and i received
some reflections and
something went uh not the way it was
intended in benthia's company
and this core belief of there's
something wrong
which
triggers there's something wrong with me
came up
in front of me
and i could just clearly see that
like a few years ago i would have
operated from it and trying to prove it
wrong and trying to prove myself
trying to prove that i did nothing wrong
and all of that and now i could just see
it and
cool it's not it's not mine yeah so i
don't have to fear it
you don't have to do anything with it
it's just showing up in front of me
which means it's not me nice so i i must
have believed in it sometime but i don't
have to believe in it and operate from
it anymore yeah so
nothing to be done just be yeah i don't
even have to do anything with it
no i must say that came after doing a
lot of work uh with doing something with
it of course looking looking at where
it's coming from looking at where i
picked it up and
surrendering to it
becoming more subtle to not get
triggered by it
yeah and then same thing i think we
talked about this in the previous uh
podcast we had where i just
lost like 4 600 profit
book a profit
just
in 12 hours
and again that
normally would have triggered so much
self-judgment and so much [ __ ] there's
something wrong with me
but now i was
i was still feeling the failure
very important
i failed
i failed just
again mathematically i intended to make
money with poker i did and then i lost
everything so i failed
no that doesn't mean anything
it just means i failed
and so
humans would would uh conflate that with
oh i felt there's something wrong with
me or i'm not good enough because i
failed because i lost the money but i
could just see i felt
cool
exciting nice
something to learn from
yes
this place so deeply into what we've
been training on in no limit society the
last
month or so while anurag has been
teaching around the cleanup process your
physical space digital space
the
relationships that you have the general
administration of your life health and
fitness your state of being all these
different things when you
go through a program like accept
yourself you're actually getting at the
roots of the cleanup process which is
exactly what enables you to come from a
pure place and same thing with me
like in mark's example
where like
there wasn't as much sensitivity for me
like in august when i was first coming
here
where i could actually see like the
the vine intertwined with the tree where
like the vine the conditioning was
running the show
and that
um then after a series of reflections
after a series of inquiry into uh that
those shadowy aspects
it surfaced as like mark describes it it
surfaces rather than it runs where
you're coming from it like pops up and
you're like
that's not me because it popped up in
front of me it's it's now like you gave
an example when you're laying and you're
seeing the clouds coming across the sky
rather than being driven by that impulse
and so that's such a good way to talk
about it because then for me it wasn't
it wasn't that
it's coming from wanting to be seen or
wanting to be validated anymore but it
was the as i'm like peaceful and still
and already more whole and i've seen
through it it just shows up as hey the
vine pops up it's like an advertisement
do you want to be seen right now do you
want to do this thing to be validated
and you can
and then it dissolves and then over time
it becomes faster and faster that you're
like catching yourself you're aware of
these patterns and it just becomes more
liberating and more pure service is so
good
yeah you become yet again who you were
before
the conditioning started
like i re i remember like actually
feeling like i was four years old and
um
just
pure playful abundant
fun exciting anything is possible
everything is possible yeah there's
there's absolutely nothing wrong with me
i'm worthy as [ __ ] yes
and seeing that
whenever those advertisements come up
they have come up sometime for the first
time
and that's where you started to oh
something bad happened
to me so that must mean that a b c d
e
and now you can be like oh
something happens
that is
connected to whatever failure or
in my case failure
for
30 years of my life that meant that
there was something wrong with me and
now i can see
i can choose that and i did choose that
already when i was five years old when
the first thing happened to me
now i reconditioned myself so much that
it's all happening for me
yeah so nothing ever happened to me yeah
so when now something shows up that i
don't like or that i feel not i don't
feel comfortable with
it's not there anymore the conflation
that that means that there's something
wrong with me
or that there's something wrong
which is something that i'm
stepping into now it's like there's
nothing ever wrong everything has always
happened for us by us through us
it's all just an experience
learning yes
and so that's the work my friend
but
we are in planet earth
right so
this is for those that are ready to
learn
to unlearn everything that you've been
taught that was true
about yourself
about this world
yeah just the feeling of no longer
looking at
somebody
and
feeling like
they're a separate person is uh it's
just so
there's nothing else that beats it um
where you get past that where you
like begin feeling the one in play with
dance conversation with itself that this
is another self and i can really feel
that and i can really tune into what's
happening at the level of our higher
selves and why we're manifesting this
conversation for our other selves that
are seeking
to know their nature nice
what are you talking about
ourselves do we have anybody yes we do
we have there's chatter there's 14 on on
youtube right now let's see who we've
had on chat
okay
hi nancy
hey guys
thank you for being here jason
what's up
nice bernard oh nice yeah this is a good
one bernard thanks bro
that was a great conversation we had on
the show i'm serving the whole so the
whole serves me nice such a good one
oh yeah he's also very familiar with law
of one very proficient in it
ah tessa
hi
they love you too
lina hi
oh
cool
so cool guys if you have any questions
also feel free to to ask them we can
look through their comments and see if
we can answer them yep
yeah and most recently um
[Music]
you can find on the accept yourself.org
website
um
there's been the creation of a lot of
art and music from people that go
through the
programs different kinds of poems and
songs and videos and
it's so beautiful because
there is something
that unlocks
and then
when you see who you are
and you see who you are not and you are
activated in your soul's blueprint
and you've
changed the narrative of your past when
you do these modules
without a doubt
its art
channels through
for sure because it's unblocked yes
how many artists
famous and non-famous
are are doing
what they're doing because it's
compensatory
yeah
because they have something to prove
to themselves and to their family
members and all spouses yes and also not
just binary too because then it also
gets intertwined where it's both like
they're activating of their soul
blueprint but it's also intertwined with
their lack belief at the same time yeah
and how much
more is possible
especially in the artist world
if everybody would be freed up from
those
basic beliefs i'm not good enough
there's something wrong with me
yeah
those basically those two but there are
so many subtleties to it
it's not safe to express myself
so
how many artists that are successful are
there because they've they've
overcompensated
and they've they've become super
successful but they could be even more
effective if they would nip their like
beliefs in the butt
and how many artists haven't we seen yet
because they are afraid of expressing
themselves because they believe they're
not good enough
so they don't exactly oh they have like
stacks of art in their basement or attic
that they are afraid of showing to the
world
because of those please
what a disservice what is this service
yeah to keep that for yourself because
you believe in illusions yeah yeah
right and so
not to judge or anything but
it's my it's my job to
to
to
assist those and people and healing
themselves so they can become whole with
the whole yes
that's pretty cool
and
can actually
bring to the world what they've come
here to bring
fearlessly yes
because they already are constituted in
their self-worth
and so then any art that comes through
is channeled from god to god
by god so or the universe yes whatever
yes i don't believe in the in the god
that sits on a
cloud with a beard judging people by the
way i was brought up that way and
i gladly i kindly said goodbye
no but
i do believe in god
but god is omni omnipresent god is you
god is in your heart so
yeah those that don't believe that
that's true in their hearts they don't
believe that they're worthy because
because of the fact that they exist
are holding out
and so what i've seen and especially in
the last program is so much art coming
through
that is so beautiful
that i can just see this wave of
earth being channeled from wholeness
from love from unity
yes
so if you're an artist and you struggle
with self-expression definitely sign up
yes
if you're an artist
and i've had these two and
you're compensating through your work
also
this is for you
but there's also uh when you're creative
making logos in a boring company every
everybody's welcome nice
let me see
i'm seeing acceptance bringing
expectance but in a great way
let me see if i can
feel what they mean hmm
yes i i think i feel what you mean
i think it's what we just talked about
like
potential for
whatever comes out of full radical
self-acceptance yes what comes out of a
being like that yes
yeah it's a channel of god's will yeah
so good it's not about you anymore yes
your life is not about you even though
i'm experiencing amazing things and i
have everything i need yes
it's not about me
in essence
of course i'm taken care of but it's not
what what it's about
yeah
also such good such good timing yeah
yeah
great timing we were talking about uh i
have everything i need and then
one of our beautiful co-hero
mentor slash team members slash hello
gina
being just sweet oh we're live sliding
into our dm sliding into our sliding
right into their dm what's up what's up
hey gina hey
thanks for having me thanks for coming
back on the show yeah i know in costa
rica we did a show together oh that's
good
yeah wow
yeah we all met in the same place
yep we met in costa rica yeah
sweet
we've had an awesome hour talking about
um
the modules and talking about like what
people can expect from the program and
um gina's been working with you since
two since accept yourself two as well
yeah well she was a participant and
except yourself too and a mentor and
accept yourself three nice yep
and then all of the
stuff that we've been doing together and
mark like just just uh social media and
promotion and website building and
and just sparring partners
which you guys have been of great help
uh
in the creation of this new
uh
iteration this new incarnation it almost
feels like
reincarnation of accept yourself yeah
yeah it's really exciting it feels like
it's gonna be the most complete version
yet
because it's been like the longest one's
been a month right 30 days yeah yeah 31
31 yes so like the three month program
feels so good yep yeah it feels like
you'll actually be able to integrate
everything that you learn in there yeah
it's gonna be really nice yeah i'm
looking forward to having a longer
period with people
yeah
i would love to hear like
um
for
gina to to share from her perspectives
we've already had our own exactly
conversation about this
so
like
yeah for you
um for you deepening your own radical
self-acceptance and then also how that's
shown up
mm-hmm yeah oh wow
that's a big let me see if i could sum
that up
um
how have i deepened it
is that your question yeah and how has
that influenced how you express yourself
more purely like in service
right yeah
yeah i think
so it's been
since the start of this year i've been
more consciously working on accepting
myself and then mark's program showed up
like uh i think i took it in
the springtime sometime right it was
like april or something yeah like april
may so
yeah it was like just perfect it was
definitely exactly what i needed
and a really good like foundational
start to that because i think
it's
it's like where do i begin almost
like
accept myself like okay now what but to
actually have that program to like work
work through kind of like step by step
of how to actually do that was super
helpful
so
since that program i feel like
then i've been able to
just look at everything basically i
didn't want to look at before like about
myself
like uh
yeah things in my past
or thing like insecurities
or anything that i
yeah i feel like it's hard for me to
accept on a daily basis it's just helped
me look at all of that
and
so i would say
yeah i think it's helped me actually
show up like as who i really am and who
i want to be because i'm not like
trying to suppress a bunch of stuff or
not look at a bunch of stuff that i'm
not accepting so
it's yeah it completely changes
everything it's so foundational
absolutely and then
yeah then i feel like i'm actually able
to connect with people and like be
available to people
like actually serve because
that's like where i'm coming from
that self-acceptance
and love so it's so yeah it's good
yeah so different
hi laurence lawrence is here you went
through the previous program
he was in my um in your group that's
awesome yeah
nice hey
so so the thing that comes up for you uh
as a keyword gina in in your previous
when you were believing in your
insecurities
how that would show up was
hiding right
oh yeah totally hiding from your
insecurities but also physically like
hiding shying away like making yourself
small yeah definitely right and so
actually napping those insecurities and
the like beliefs that come
that they come from
actually doing the work
has allowed you to become more of who
you truly are yeah totally
because you you don't let those
assumptions around the show anymore yeah
you're ahead of the wave of that yeah
totally and so it's a totally different
being
right
yeah and with you it's like totally
different as well like not like because
you you were the opposite of that
which is also close to how i was like
over compensating
like showing off like showing how much
value you have this month
and and you know like
but coming from the same like assumption
in a different uh phrasing maybe but
yeah it all comes down to
lack of self-worth
or
something being wrong or whatever and
seeing how
it
once you see it it's a disservice to
to operate from it
because you know better
right
so yeah and it's cool like just to
actually
become conscious of those things
because before that i
actually didn't know that that's what i
was doing
right it's like maybe i could say that
yeah i have that tendency but i didn't
see it that clearly like oh that's
exactly how i
i um avoid things or like that's how i
deal with my insecurities or that's how
i deal with like my fears or anything so
you get to know yourself really well
actually of like all your
patterns and
yeah then like you're able to just
release those and it's yeah
so
life-changing really
lawrence calls you the best mentor ever
oh lawrence lauren said he was going to
join i love lawrence
oh like the next
program yeah oh it's sweet
[Music]
lovely
yeah there's another
there's another thread there um
which is
like
me expressing myself
with lots of jargon and
[Laughter]
like look at me and all my metaphysics
look at me
uh i know true nature based on all these
words and concepts
um
and so that's another way of phrasing
what gina just said where it's like uh i
didn't really see that expressing myself
that way was coming from a place of in a
sense unworthiness and and lack
because it was more about how much i can
share and be seen for how much i know
even more so that it was still
intertwined with also wanting to share
with people something of value that
would help them in their journey but it
was more the tree and the vine were
inter intertwined like that
and so the process of going inward and
accepting myself and looking at
these shadowy roots it actually enabled
me to peel that sticker off of the
sticker paper more and come from a pure
place
yeah nice marianne marianne hey hi
hi
oh it's so nice that marianne's here
marianne is also part of the team
has been
and
it's going to help again
so super excited
she's been a mentor right like she's
been a mentor marianna's been here from
the start
so it's great to have you back
and excited to jump on a goal with you
this weekend
there was another really good thread um
so we've been talking about mentoring a
lot we didn't talk about this too much
yet but so the there's 12 sessions over
the three months and there's also 12
breakout sessions yes
um so every week there'll be a breakout
session led by one of the mentors that's
been a part of like the previous
programs
and so
um it's kind of like basically the
integration of the teachings that are
taught on the session day with mark
right yes you get in smaller groups you
get into smaller groups and it's
basically um
it's like sharing whatever comes up and
talking about it and um
just yeah just being together in a
smaller intimate group so you can
integrate the high intensity of some of
the sessions
where there isn't that much time always
for everybody to
have a moment to share
what they're going through so those
breakout calls are essential to
to the integration of
of all the practices and modalities that
we'll be going through
yep by the way
that says asking gina post realizing
these patterns
curious if you went through a period of
being hard on yourself in an attempt to
hold that new standard of freedom
nice yeah that's a great question yeah
for sure i remember our call
oh yeah you asked yeah maybe that's a
good entry point what was i asked you
asked no i've seen my core leg belief
and i've admitted the feed to it oh yeah
i'm like how long is it going to take
for it to go away
yeah like wanting to get rid of stuff
and i think that's actually um there's
just so many little like nuances to
accepting yourself
um that yeah it's just uh like that's
one of them like trying to get rid of
stuff basically and we dove into where
it was coming from the same yeah it's
assumption it's basically like the
question itself because you're not
accepting that you want it to go away
yep so you're trying yeah it's coming
from the same place so you could you
could actually translate that
that the question itself
if you went through a video so the
period of being hard on yourself is
coming from the same pattern that you're
trying to get rid of
yeah so it comes from the
trying to get rid of
and that's not the intention of this
work it's not to try to get rid of the
pattern it's trying to see it for what
it is and then just let it be
yeah
and then it
it's like it comes up in front of you
you don't need to do anything with it so
you don't have to be hard on yourself
for the fact that it comes up in front
of you
because being hard on yourself is
another pattern that you're then seeing
so just see oh
i'm being hard on myself that is also
not me
i've started believing in whatever made
me
be hard on myself but i don't have to
i think ben bentin said to me once uh
why don't you stop beating yourself up
and just kick yourself in the dick once
yeah
so yeah yep
it's a great way to put it too yeah
how long will it take however long it
will take
right yeah would you say it still comes
up sometimes and some successfully yeah
totally it's like layers of an onion
yeah you you so you're seeing that it's
not you
yeah so you just can just accept it and
sometimes it's like ah these are not my
beliefs these are humanities beliefs
that i picked up because of
wanting to be a service to this planet
yeah and i think that's really like one
core of
he's checking on some sound or something
um
the core of accepting
yourself is
not resisting those things like
i remember yeah seeing a lot of my
patterns or
yeah as like you start to understand
stuff that like you're doing
and you you're like okay that's not
ideal like i want to stop doing that
and then you can start yeah
there can be a tendency to
be really hard on yourself or want to
get rid of it i definitely
have gone through a lot of that um but
just to see that the more that i
actually
just really accept it exactly the way it
is then
that actually like takes the
yeah like takes the
i don't even know what the right phrase
like the wind out of the sails in a
sense like it just kind of dissolves
after that
yes and uh yeah the more that
i've resisted things or like really
wanted them to go away
i realized it was just
like the same pattern basically and
sometimes
i did that because i didn't want to let
go of it
i just like wanted to keep
obsessing about it in a sense and
there's yeah
something to learn from that but
yeah just accepting it and then it just
naturally yeah dissolves
yeah
more and more
yeah i like how you went into as it is
and and the full acceptance of it as it
is and the investigation of it so there
is a desire to like unfreeze your will
there's a desire to know yourself to
accept yourself become the creator
there's that desire
um
for service for freedom truth is what
makes it so that
what uh the it liberates you from
resistance because as you become more
accepting of the conditioning that you
designed for yourself that then it
becomes a self-purification engine it
runs it runs itself because you become
more of the field and you become less of
the contracted sense of identity that's
trying to get things
for
itself
and it's not know yourself resist
yourself become the creator right
[Laughter]
it's accept yourself
so it's being hard on yourself accepting
yourself
you can ask yourself that question
yeah right also another thing i was
thinking of was
um
there's a tendency it's like know
yourself
there's a tendency to want to fix
yourself essentially like know yourself
fix yourself become the creator
and it's like oh wait that actually
there's nothing to fix
and i think that's uh
been one of the main takeaways that i've
taken from your program it's like
there's really nothing to fix about
myself even like being in a program you
can kind of get the sense of like oh i'm
here to like
improve myself and like fix myself in a
sense but
it's not about that at all like that's
not the goal ever yeah otherwise it
would be called fix yourself yeah
fix yourself
jeez
yeah stop doing it
yeah it's like wow it's really just
accepting myself and loving myself like
that's it like there's there's nothing
else
and that can just happen in a moment
like there's nothing to change how long
has humanity been fixing itself
how many eons
right um
and just and just naturally because
purify yourself um is like a byproduct
of the
knowing yourself and accepting yourself
so it's not like fix yourself it's more
like purification is the byproduct of
knowing and accepting yourself which
then
enhances the way that you show up in
service to life
it's like fixing yourself is again like
imagine yourself being a five-year-old
child that has just experienced
something that's traumatic
like somebody hit you in the face and
and you in that moment that child
started believing there's something
wrong with me right
fast forward 20 years or whatever your
age right now
whoever is 30 years 40 years 50 years
whoever is watching
the moment something
occurs that gives you the same
experience that you had being smacked in
the face something not going the way you
intended or not going
the way you desired it to go whatever
and that same thing
comes up there's something wrong with me
imagine
that being the five-year-old child that
experiences this for the first time
and you're trying to fix the child
you're basically saying there's
something wrong with your child you're
basically amplifying the leg belief
you're not helping it
by fixing it
you're telling the child actually
there's something wrong with you yeah
it's true
this means there's something wrong with
you instead of
come here everything is all right
nothing is wrong with you
it's just a punch in the face
you're okay i accept you
cry all you want have all the feelings
you're having it's all good
so
if you come from fix yourself 20 years
from now you're still fixing yourself
because you assume that you're broken
yeah
and what you're really wanting is that
self-acceptance and love like that is
who you really are and that's like what
you're sort of trying to get to yeah by
fixing yourself but it just doesn't work
yeah
yeah it doesn't work yeah it just
doesn't work fix yourself it's like a
little loop
you know
you'll never get out of it yeah it's
like a little loop
because you assume that there's
something wrong with you in the first
place yes yes that's why let's fix
yourself that's the key yeah exactly
yeah there's the assumptions you get
something wrong in the first place
exactly yeah
exactly
it's so good
another question for gina is that
um so now
after going through the program and also
being a mentor and now being in this
field for four months together
um i just would like to hear you share
about how
you've seen more into the patterns of
how consciousness expresses itself
so will you give us a bit of insight
into
um your new
like jedi like perception and like
ability your new like superpowers being
unlocked in the way that you see how
consciousness engages with itself
okay
i could say a lot on that i think
i could tell as i've
just become more of who i am it just
it feels like well number one
i feel like i'm in tune with everything
more
it's like i can just see more
um like
how people are feeling or like what's
needed in a situation
what i need even
um
or even just
increased intuition about like things
that might happen
um
yeah i think it's just
whatever
is sort of like a byproduct of being
more connected in a sense like
everything
downstream of that so
yeah
i'd say
mostly that i think
just being in tune with people more
i would say
yeah but then also
i think
being more in tune with
what i actually want also and so you
kind of feel like
there's
things that you want to be expressed
through you like maybe it's a new
project or it's just something you want
to do
and
to allow those things to come out in a
more
unfiltered way or a more pure way yeah
so that's definitely been one yeah what
we talked about that's what we talked
about before
gina came in
when i spoke to the artist
like there's nothing in the way so
whatever wants to be expressed doesn't
get filtered through
there's something wrong with me or
i'm not good enough it just comes true
because
because it wants to because
because you are in tune as you said
yourself with the universe with your
worthiness with with your wholeness so
whatever comes through it is not
filtered through any just blockages it
just wants to yes yeah
this is what's needed this is what this
body needs this is what that body needs
this is what
the field needs this is whatever it is
it just comes true totally yeah so
everything you create just is more
pure more beautiful it's like whatever
it is
whether it's art or like a conversation
with someone or anything
that you create or just your experience
is just like all
more loving beautiful
yeah connected
yeah
yeah of course that doesn't oh that
you don't owe that only to the
acceptance of program of course always
also truly work with continue and team
and snowden society and all of that so
it's
and i would say that is also where my
program came from it's like the work
i've been doing with venting
and
just the last years just
wow
so this
ah
i just love seeing this
yeah youtube as well
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah likewise
and that plays so well into what was
just shared about this
um
like the emptying out of of the
conditioning and the self-interest and
um how that enables like you were
sharing like this purity with the field
and like this effortless action with the
field what this body needs what that
body needs what's intuitively um
arising in the moment and um
that yeah that that itself that level of
connectedness to the field consciousness
is like
it's like uh
it's like the most delicious food you
could
eat and you're like constantly eating it
like dessert all day
it's so good though it is it's so good
thank you jason
see you in the program
oh he's gonna join nice
nice
awesome sweet guys
um
let's see what else uh
what else to wrap on um
maybe it's it's relevant to share that
um
the session that uh bentino will uh lead
will be on um
getting over your core lack belief
yep
so i still have to talk with him about
it specifically but it is surrounding
the uh
the acceptance of what you're not
so
those core limitations like beliefs that
you picked up and
i'm not going to spoil too much about it
but it's uh it's gonna be foundational
definitely an exclusive as [ __ ] yes so
cool yeah i'm excited for that
so it's an opportunity for those people
in the program to be the only people
that are uh that will be asking
questions to continue and that doesn't
happen too much with such a small wow
yeah that's actually
in a goal it's really exclusive yeah
yeah wow
that's great
and corey on another story later later
on last part
discovering your or accepting your soul
blueprint wow
which is all about expression and and
that's where she excels
bringing into
manifestation your expression
cool
so
so yeah
january 4th
2022 start of the program
um
[Music]
the link in the bio to accept yourself
dot org
um
there's also a free discovery call
so
that's like about a 15 minute or so yeah
so when you go to the website uh you
will find all the information there and
if you click join now you will be taken
to a
calendar software where you can book a
free 15-minute discovery call in which i
also in that
software ask you to answer specific
questions so i know what your intention
is where you see yourself
um
why you are sparked all of those
questions and then we will have a call
to discuss those and
further
logistics will be discussed in that call
also about payment and and all of that
stuff
so everyone that signs up goes through
that call yes
everybody has to have a call with me
first gotcha yeah because i just want to
know who you are and if
if this is actually for you yeah and
just to confirm and to feel each other's
energy i find it crucial to
know who i'm working with before they
sign up so yeah yeah
i love the attention you give each
participant it's really good
it's very important
yeah definitely helps so much
two hats
unicorn
and little kissy face
right back at you
nice
yeah three months starting january
fourth
two calls per per week one call with me
one call with one of these two or the
other
breakup mentors and then two bonus calls
with continue and with corey
an awesome telegram group with daily
inspiration mark's presence in that
telegram group
um a like-minded community such an
important thing yes because we're
so much of us seek people that care
about consciousness they care about
purity they care about service truth um
and so sometimes
it can be hard to find people that are
aligned in that way and like this is a
great way to find that like-minded
community
and like some things that can come out
of it like we've had a relationship come
out of it for example uh
we've had we are working on a accept
yourself song
which is still in production which when
you go to my instagram page and you
go to the latest uh video where i talk
about the accept yourself program
at the end you'll find
snippets of poems and art that has been
created and the song the beginning of
the song is
as in that video as well
and
that so there are so many things that
will come out of it it's not just a
program of self-improvement
it's foundational
[ __ ] for your life
against pardon the profanity american
people but
lawrence
lawrence says
it's also a great place to find triggers
to practice with definitely such a good
point yeah oh yeah nice for sure yeah
yeah it will definitely happen
it's such a great way actually to
like
if you sign up for the program it just
will completely change the flavor of
your life because like you'll be in this
container for three months so that's
just gonna like change everything you do
yeah basically i'm so stoked about three
months it's like
yeah yeah well i've
yeah
as i said in the beginning like 30 days
i loved working with people so
intensively we used to have two calls
per week
with me but
i'm realizing now that this three-month
container is
this next level because it takes
it just
is more time and
just imagine
the shift you can go through in 90 days
cool
let's see
in terms of consciousness there's
nothing like realizing the earth
and space is fake the sky is a clock
it's amazing yeah but bro you have total
uh right to believe in what you believe
[Music]
yep
so also the link in the bio is to um
mark's instagram so you can also follow
him there and you can see some of his
other uh testimonials are posted there
on his instagram page um
and on the website
yeah and on the website um
so the um
you have about about a month uh to
yeah to get involved in the program
um
limited spots available so do sign up
for this discovery call and
um
and
also share this is really good to share
like if you feel like
accept yourself and the radical
self-acceptance has really rang true for
you um
then share this with other people share
this this conversation this podcast with
other people um
and see if it's what they need i
remember after my own program um after
taking it um the second program after
um going through it that it was so clear
to me that there were people that were
seeking that the program was a perfect
fit for so do send the program to other
people that you feel like it's resonant
for
this conversation
you can leave a comment also below with
your with your thoughts on radical self
acceptance or your own journey with it
as well we'd love to hear from you
like the video um
[Music]
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet also um you can check out more
content coming up on the accept yourself
youtube channel
um more clips more marketing content to
be coming out soon
from the previous sessions also
more art more art
yep more songs
poems
videos
[Music]
what else fam
pretty good i think we can wrap it i
think we can wrap it too
awesome everyone
accept yourself
the journey uh how does that how does it
work if i play this they'll hear it does
it work okay let's just start end with
that we're gonna sign off with our
official song so good
this is a song that came out of the
program like one of the participants
made this song
[Music]
yourself into the
do you still feel the light to live
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
i love that like that you know
uh
the journey of a thousand
miles begins with the first step except
yourself so good yeah that's your slime
so good
beautiful beautiful way to wrap
awesome
good job guys
sign up for accept yourself much love
thank you for watching this all you're
amazing